[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kbhd here okay
quick before i start this tour i just
want to give a quick shout out to an
instagrammer named jvnb
who actually made this quick video and
i've reshared it of over 700 rubik's
cubes and then organize them all to make
the text mkbhd and my face it's kind of
amazing i'll leave a link to it below
it's really cool and i've also never
actually solved a rubik's cube in my
entire life like from start to finish so
that made that much more impressive for
me anyway let's get into the tour hey
what's up guys mkbhd here and welcome to
the desktor setup for early 2020. this
is probably the last tour that there's
going to be in this space as we're going
to be moving to a new space in a couple
of weeks like i've mentioned so that's
really exciting but i figured i'd give
you an updated setup tour and it's of
the stuff that i use to work and get
work done now i already know a lot of
the comments on these are already about
this costs so much money this is super
expensive but just know that this is not
my personal setup at home this is my
work setup and this is also the
culmination of many years more than 10
years now of building a setup like this
for work specifically to edit videos
that you see here so that's the point of
it so maybe me sharing it you can enjoy
it or get ideas for your own setups and
things like that either way i think it's
a lot of fun so let's just get started
[Music]
so the best place to start is always the
physical desk itself i've talked about
this a lot i've had this since college
this is a custom sized eight foot by i
think three foot
next desk air pro
it's an incredible piece of thin metal
it's a motorized desk so it goes up and
down and uh it happens to be uh one of
the oldest pieces of the setup and it
also has some battle scars from me maybe
putting things down too hard on it but
that's part of the setup is you get some
stuff that gets worn in and it gets used
a lot speaking of which
that's also the chair that i've used
this is the herman miller embody if
you're going to sit in a chair for many
hours at a time which people who edit
videos typically do might as well save
your back spend a little extra get a
share that's really comfortable and
supports your spine which these chairs
do so these two things have been with me
for probably the longest of anything
else here so i'll start all the way on
the left side of the desk with again one
of the oldest pieces which is the studio
monitors the speakers these are yamaha
hs8s so it's an eight inch woofer and a
one-inch tweeter and these things are
sitting on top of these oralx acoustic
foam pieces if this was just sitting on
the desk by itself it would rattle the
desk a lot and that's not great for
audio at all so they're sitting on these
pads which they have been for a while
and these are incredible these are
internally amplified perfectly balanced
studio monitors
i have had opportunities to switch to
others but these also are really clean
looking really good sounding never had
any problems with them again i've had
these for like six or seven years at
least too so i love the yamaha hs8s
there's also smaller hs5s and hs7s
then next to that behind this monitor
here
is what's called the promis pegasus i've
also had this for a while if you've seen
the older setup tour videos you'll
notice a bit of a theme a lot of this
stuff has been here for a bit but that's
an 80 terabyte raid array and that's
where i've backed up all of my videos
since like 2013. and then another thing
that's special about this desk is it's
got a built-in power supply right
underneath which is like literally
bolted to it so i have 12 power outlets
there so that's good for cable
management and that also lets me have
this wireless charger here on my desk
and uh i just plugged in a oneplus power
cable so if i have a wireless charging
phone or a wired phone they can both
plug in here while i'm at work and then
i have these black air pods pro from
colorware i've showed these before in a
separate video if i'm on a video call or
an interview or a skype or something
like that those are the headphones of
choice and then of course is the biggest
addition to actually what's on the desk
itself which is apple's pro display xdr
this is the matte nano texture version
it works great in here because there's
lots of lights all over the place
there's natural lighting coming in here
so no glare no regrets and these are off
both on the pro stand and they're both
sitting next to each other in glorious
6k
low key one of the most underrated
things about these this is going to
sound like such a complaint but it's
true is it's really hard to find
high-res 6k hdr
wallpapers for dual screens so you need
like a 12k setup happening so i've just
reversed a wallpaper and put it on both
monitors just to make it look kind of
nice but that's something i've found is
tough but that's what's going on here on
top of the desk my dual monitor editing
setup my dual monitor productivity setup
everything about it i'm so glad to have
dual monitors again it's been a long
time since i've had that imac pro for a
couple years but i love having two
screens now no matter what you think
about the pro stands or whatever you
think about the monitors they are
actually pretty useful they're plugged
into the mac pro which i'll get to in a
second but they also have a couple usb
type-c ports on the back and since these
don't have a webcam built in i have a
little magnetic connecting logitech 4k
webcam on top but also since the
computer is not on the desk anymore like
it was with the imac pro there's a
couple other things plugged into the
monitor that aren't plugged into the mac
pro directly and that is this mini mag
reader which
it's not as fast when it's going through
through the monitor but it works and
there's also the dongle to connect to
this mouse which i've had problems with
it being underneath the desk so when i
plugged the dongle in from logitech's mx
master 3 into the mac pro directly it
would have to go through the desk and
this mouse would stutter like crazy so i
found that putting a dongle behind the
monitor and then connecting it to the
mouse worked way better so if that's
something you're dealing with hopefully
that helps also pro tip if you ever need
help plugging in something behind the
monitor something i've done for a little
while is just pop up the selfie camera
and go ahead and stick it behind the
monitor and then you can see the ports
and this is how i've known how exactly
to plug in stuff or how many ports i
have left so
fun fact there i did that with the imac
too and then all the way over here on
the right is the apollo twin mark ii
which is actually a little bit more
powerful a little more capable although
i really don't use it for what it's good
for it's a space gray basically
glorified volume button but also has a
bunch of plugins and things if people
work with audio but basically that's
connected to and powering the studio
monitors and if i want to plug in
headphones that's where i do that too so
then last but not least is essentially
the control setup which is essentially
the mouse the magic trackpad and the
keyboard so the mouse like i said mx
master iii it's got a little bit of a
custom laser etching on it which is
pretty sweet and you had that pro tip of
how to make sure it doesn't stutter it
also connects by usb type c it was in a
dope tech episode and it's sitting on a
red artisan mouse pad this mousepad i've
tried to buy again because you can see
it's like getting really worn out but
it's i can't find it for sale exactly
this one anymore so i feel like my next
mousepad is going to be a slightly
different
red mousepad but it is what it is it
hasn't moved in a long time so i like it
and then over here magic trackpad 2. i
just use this literally to go back and
forth between spaces i have dual
monitors but i also often have a lot of
stuff going on with final cut pro and
then back to the web browser and then my
dual screen editing setup so that's why
i have the magic track pad and i've
often used them both at once that's just
sort of the way my setup's been for a
while and the keyboard
is one of my new favorite little pieces
this is the keytron
keychron k2
it's rgb it's wireless it doesn't have
the number pad and i don't really miss
it i don't use it that much but i found
that these brown switches have been my
favorites that i've tried in the
mechanical keyboard so far and i have a
couple custom keycaps like the red
ascend key up here and i don't know just
feels like at home it's a very unique
looking piece it's not as low profile as
the mac keyboard
and it sounds really good
but yeah that's the keyboard that i've
been using for a while it gets really
loud when i'm editing but that's my
control setup oh i almost forgot i've
typically had my smartphone or
smartphones of choice daily carries
whatever you want to call them just
straight up on the desk but if there's
like some debris or something and you
put it face down then it gets a little
dicey so
i have uh the microfiber cloth that came
with the pro display xdr just put it
right in the middle of the desk
phone goes face down on that when it's
not charging doesn't distract me i keep
it face down
that's about it for on the desk so that
of course brings us to what is
underneath the desk which is
the new mac pro so i've typically not
had anything under my desk
and i'm working on a full review of this
machine this is now the one that i've
bought not apple's review unit so it is
a 28 core
i have right now 768 gigs of ram which
is insane vega 2 vega pro 2 duo it's
been excellent so far and i'm editing
this video on that i dropped an 8k q a
it's been awesome but now my biggest
problem problem really is that cables
have to get from the mac pro
up to what's on the desk again and it's
a motorized desk and it moves up and
down but while i'm standing now you have
two cables to both the monitors and a
cable to the apollo twin mark ii and one
up to the pegasus so it's a little bit
messier looking
but i'm willing to work with that to
have this machine here but they actually
make a version of this desk with a
little
holder for a cpu i think i might end up
trying to get one of those and attaching
it or something like that but the mac
pro has been sitting under the desk i've
had no airflow problems down here or
anything the air goes straight through
from left to right so when it's
rendering you can stick your hand on the
back and feel the hot air but you know
no dust really down here or anything i
haven't kicked it so it's just been sort
of comfortably sitting down there so
that's the mac pro and how it's
contributed to this setup and that
review is coming soon and then if i go
ahead and slide over here
this is how i bring it down to sitting
position
so that's pretty much it it's pretty
simple this is where i've been sitting
when editing and making what you've seen
for the better part of the last three
years or so
and we're really excited to be moving
into our new space and using everything
we've learned from the evolution of this
for that but even things like the the
sound panels behind here on the wall
which have helped with reverb because
these speakers are so massive there's
foam in the corners that are called base
traps there's all sorts of things that
we've removed that have been here before
but we've ended up with i think a pretty
clean
simple functional
setup i don't know if i'd call it
minimal but it's felt pretty clean the
whole time so when my desk doesn't have
other stuff on it this is what it looks
like also one more thing i forgot to
mention
the mac pro doesn't have an sd card
reader built into it right and i guess
that makes sense pros don't necessarily
need media card readers built in
but just for someone that has the mac
pro underneath their desk that means in
order to read sd cards they either have
to plug it into the back of the pro
display xdr and then somehow plug it in
there not ideal or
get this thing sticking out the top of
the mac pro and then plug it in there
also not ideal so i have to get one that
like sort of cables out onto the desk
and looks a little uglier and it's
another cable and then when i lower the
desk it sort of gets extra slack it's a
whole weird thing so i've just basically
kept this on the desk and plugged it in
when i needed it um
minor detail anyway that's pretty much
it for the setup tour 2020. it feels
like a short one but i didn't really
talk about like other stuff on if you
want uh what's on my smartphone video or
what's on my daily tech video i've also
considered
an everyday carry video like a backpack
video but if you have a suggestion
please leave it in the comment section
below because that's where we get our
best ideas so anyway that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace